[Music]
that looks so good gorgeous
and look at that I like the plating too
short whole pizza
this is our first time meeting this
pizza yeah remember we've always had the
crispy ham Peter switching it up today
pizzeria pizza
[Music]
Italy or what I know right this is so
rough man you're sick too shiny she's
not delivery its DiGiorno
hey guys we're finally home after
traveling so much recently and we
decided hey you know what we haven't
really paid much attention to our home
so we wanted to take today to clean our
patio
cuz it's such a nice place and such a
nice area we never get to use it it's
always so dusty full of spider webs and
like yeah it's just like it's been very
neglected it's been a neglected part of
our home Thank You Monty right now
[Laughter]
things were like howling people are like
I gotta have a kitchen as an island then
I gotta add this by the kitchen but I
don't cook things I really love it but
we just never use no audio and so yeah
we decided hey you know you guys have
been seeing us traveling non-stop on
this channel it's just been trouble blog
after travel after travelogue and we did
see some comments so like hey we want to
see you guys at home too so we're like
oh yeah we forget to bring you guys
along with our daily lives like I don't
know cuz I guess in my mind our daily
like our day-to-day things I'm like you
guys are gonna be bored of that you
don't wanna see me just hang out at home
working on Jake Amy goes all the time
I'm fortified yeah all right so we got
window cleaner for the table and the
bench and then we got this like blood
killing spree thing and then this cute
little song it's actually to try to chop
down this huge like arm of the palm tree
that's covering his girls
completely it's on a rescue mission I
have to go and save my sander and my
barbecue craft it's been a very long
time since
tended to this area dust just covered
everything spiderwebs none of you could
see that but this is pretty crazy and we
just gotta get rid of all of this is all
trash here this has just taken over it
completely I guess you were right this
is what is it Jumanji keep the jungle
yeah cuz look the girls are back there
yeah the last time I came out here I
literally put my grills over there
because I was like oh yeah perfectly
yeah not anymore and then over here in
the walkway oh my gosh yeah we get to
chop this down I just poked my eye there
and I know we have all these weeds oh
yeah by the way you guys wanted to know
an update on our plant
so this is our tomato plant oh it was
hanging on for dear life we're such bad
plant owners look at that week their
season their only we can replant them
yeah it's the sun-dried tomatoes this is
very very good quality stuff right here
you've done I eat it yeah I didn't think
so
oh man scary saved your money we needed
you money foods under yeah this is our
garlic plant we actually never harvested
our garden part yeah
oh look a cute little white what is that
moth butterfly well anyway yeah we did
grow plenty of garlic but we never
harvested them just like the tomatoes
and they ended up going bad very bad my
parents at least four good cat parents
look there was pleased and happy over
there
she's staring at the spiders they
actually really get very much
entertained dealing with the spider
because they're always like chasing them
but it's so cute because they can't
reach the bugs they're on the other side
of the glass we got to get rid of this
chair I don't know
we insist on keeping it like no one can
sit on this why do we keep it
I bought this bench when we first moved
here because since we take off our shoes
every time we go inside the house I was
like oh look a little shoe bench thing
for all of our guests our guests never
use it because it's way too dusty every
time they come over really we don't
wanna put our shoes there all right we
have a lot of work to do first things
first we should throw these away throw
this away throw that whole corner away
and then once we throw all that away I
think the next thing we should do is
chop down that thing oh yeah so what I
was mentioning here yeah so when I was
saying about the salt it's for this
things like I don't know if you guys can
make that out there's like a arm thing
is what's creating all of this excess
mess here so if I can somehow get in
there but it was actually super pokey
like it really hurts baby that's not
gonna that's not gonna work before the
individual oh yeah you're right you're
right we can get to the big thing then
we take this oh you're so smart
I'm married a smart one oh yeah I'm
actually really looking forward to this
cuz I love doing this stuff whenever I
get
[Music]
I'm fine oh what's the fun part you're
so hot when you do hard work like this
[Applause]
doing things that look very fun to me
nope and looking at all this right over
here I'm like that doesn't that look
very fun either it's just that's a chore
I had the whole house to myself and they
moved out that house was pretty big and
had a lot of landscaping stuff I'll just
spend the whole day outdoors pending
Tillamook wrasses up
they're crazy alright so in the time it
took me to throw out all the trash and
furniture that we didn't wash my super
wife has been chopping away at all the
money stuff there's like spiders and I
just I'll deal with dirt getting in my
cuts I could see you my crew my baby
we're coming to catch you I see you too
smoker this we don't even have actual
like shears they thought we had that I
wasn't mailing enough to buy the big
ones I just bought that cut these little
small little branches off yeah I was
just waiting for you to hand me the
shears exactly been waiting you for her
okay I'll take the shears
[Applause]
you look hot out of shirt on good like
this is this is the way of getting rid
of them - okay so just be really careful
with that said that that's where I got
cut like in saw in the movie saw you
pull it back and it cuts you oh my gosh
come on you guys they'll hold it with
your fingers I have a tool I'm gonna use
it for yeah we could see the grills now
you can finally start drilling again
I didn't grill it the entire summer oh
yeah the first year you have to even
grill this is a good year not to grill
though because home for that reason and
because it's been like a hundred degrees
every day like it's been way too hot to
the girl I wouldn't want you to grow
boogers coming out oh you gotta go wash
my hands allergy I don't know every time
I do something you're allergic to work
no no honestly I don't even know what
triggers it but there's just these
random moments in my life where my nose
just starts getting really watery you
know a dog's always have wet noses so
I'm a little puppy I don't know I always
have a wet nose for some reason you know
what it is that what I don't like about
this kind of work
I don't like maintenance maintenance is
boring I like creating I realize that's
why I like cooking and doing videos I
think that's why me you are such a good
a double because I don't like creating
things out of nothing like if you give
me a blank canvas I'd freak out oh my
god I don't know what to do with this
but if you give me something that needs
to be edited or like just like finesse
time like
all right that's where I excel so like
maintenance is my forte perfect you can
do all the maintenance work over here I
look so naked now
actually jiggles like jello yeah this
ain't gonna work
you're gonna break this off before you
even make a dent
[Applause]
that's all looks funny
fix it the tree now this cleany made me
hungry I think we should eat here
because we never come out here enjoy it
fruits of our labor I factored that one
again what baby I think it was boogers
so do you want to have dinner while
we're clean well we're dirty
I'm not eat dirty yeah okay that was
just testing the waters of that I know I
know that the other answer was the right
answer
full shower first
[Music]
look it's all clean now
[Music]
okay now I'm all nice and clean I was
feeling so gross especially because it's
been so hot recently where I'm like oh
my gosh I just I just finished getting a
little bit done up just you know just
those tiny little bits for my hubby to
enjoy a nice evening with his wife as I
was taking a shower though I was
realizing I think I got like five
blisters on my hands from what I was
doing out there
today cuz I was the one that was
sweeping the entire patio while Casey
was picking up all the trash so it was
good teamwork but because of the broom I
have like a crazy blister warming right
here and then on this hand
I don't you guys could see that but it's
actually like I have a blister like it's
like bubbly right here and then I have
one right here and I have one right
there and then I have one right here to
times up I wish you guys could smell
this so good it makes all these blisters
worth it whew that looks so good oh I
love it
oh yeah oh yeah that is perfection
oh my gosh Casey hurry up and shower I'm
so hungry don't want to eat this right
now
oh no we get to try it something we get
to finally try this baby out because
usually we've been having Christmas ham
pizzas and since it already has its own
pan we haven't been able to test this
baby out but now we got the pizzeria and
it's a circle we get to try out these up
here
so excited you know I was thinking it
would be really cute and romantic if you
pulled out some candles and we have
these French candles that my cousin
gifted us for our weddings I'm like mom
I'll be perfect out there these are the
candles I was talking about they smell
amazing
[Music]
[Music]
how that blisters I can't do this
without it I wanted to be all romantic
you have it already my blisters yeah the
champagne just exploded on me I was
trying to open it but my hands have
blisters and I was about to quit and
then I walked away and then it just
popped on its own oh yeah we do looking
all handsome I don't know
felt like the occasion needed us to
dress up but I won't do my hair in this
nighttime I know I didn't really do my
hair either I just kind of let her feel
all frizzy I thought something happened
like I got scared too I can't wait to
see that footage of a defend people off
the comb Shh
okyou even had sight the sound effects
no one else I forgot to mention though I
did my nails today and I did all that
outside why crazy luckily though they
stayed really nice and intact so hey do
I put this on a pizza peel first and
then cut it or going cut it and then
rearrange it on the beach peel I would
cut it there first so we don't cut this
oh you gonna keep the pizza peel nice
[Music]
beautiful gorgeous and look at that I
like the plating dish or no pizza all
right got the wine I was actually
surprised you with AI pouring it and
everything but then the whole pop
explosion thing but I do have a little
surprise I'll say let's do yeah you like
the candle oh yeah it's perfect
that's already kind of going down in
Italy or what you guys start playing the
Italian music right now I don't write
when the moon it you're like a big pizza
pie that's amore I had to finish that I
couldn't help it
this is so romantic
[Music]
love you I love these like small little
moments in our marriage it's really cute
I look back and I'm like we're cute
[Music]